utopia 56 n'est plus nomades après des
années de squats dans différents lieux
de l'agglomération tourangelle tour nord
saint pierre des corps ou encore le plan
b l'hiver dernier dans le quartier
velpeau les mineurs non accompagnés sont
désormais hébergés dans un site pérenne
depuis octobre quatorze jeunes ils sont
accueillis pour quelques mois ça mail
colin ils sont une dizaine en ce moment
de cinq nationalités différentes
j'ai été mais à l'arrêt et tous ces gars
là sam et au lycée professionnel tous
voient en cours comme lui et rentrer
vers 19 heures la journée la maison
reste fermé t'es vraiment un lieu
normalement de mise à l'abri et puis à
côté on propose des activités à l'école
alternative du trot puis à 56 le matin
le midi les jeunes mangent à la table de
jeanne-marie et l'après midi on propose
aussi des activités foot activités
manuelles 14 places sont disponibles
répartis dans des chambres comme celle
ci tout le mobilier provient de dons
même chose pour l'alimentaire soit c'est
des citoyens qu'il les apporte soit
c'est les jeunes qui cuisinent avec la
nourriture qu'on avait dans la cuisine
un bail à un lieu stable payé par utopia
56 les démarches administratives pour
être considéré comme mineur non
accompagné prennent entre 6 et 24 mois
mais l'accueil ici reste temporaire
évidemment entre
deux et trois mois après on espère
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient reconnus
mineurs et franc charge par le
département soit qu'ils aillent chez des
hébergeurs solidaire l'on ne recherche
activement en ce moment avec la pandémie
les arrivées de mineurs non accompagnés
ont fortement diminué selon les derniers
chiffres elles sont divisées par deux
dans le département en 2020